[Music]
he was acquitted by a jury but still
causes leftist fury
several lefty student groups at arizona
state university they have a university
there
are campaigning to get kyle rittenhouse
kicked out of the school's online
classes
they call him murderer kyle rittenhouse
and they're hosting a rally in support
of their demands which includes banning
written house reaffirming support for
the multicultural center as a safe space
from white supremacy which is like
demanding a safe space from ghosts
they also want funds redirected from the
asu police department to the
multicultural center because a lack of
police really helped matters in kenosha
and finally and oddly to quote make gut
fell do his show
shirtless that's funny i can't argue
there susan the kids want what they want
stop laughing
now the school confirmed that
rittenhouse was enrolled as a non-degree
online student but he hasn't gone
through the admissions process and is no
longer enrolled which means he filled
out an online form where they will take
anyone and the fact is written house was
found not guilty it's only fair he
deserves another shot which is poor
wording on my part
meanwhile asu students for socialism
said they don't feel safe with kyle
being at the school even if it's just
online
but with socialists that week how are
they going to implement gulags
a little history humor there
it's sad how much the school's changed
playboy magazine once named asu the
number one party school back in 2002. we
asked an asu student who graduated that
year to comment
so rick what do you think about this
written house story i don't know why
people are worried about danger from
going to school with someone on the
internet hell i took basket weaving with
the unabomber i'm okay
wow so how else has college changed
since you graduated it was constant
parties back then i would go to a keger
then i would follow that up with a more
relaxing caker then i would sleep during
class the only danger we worried about
back then was was babes tripping over
themselves to get to me
boner i thought you died let's go drink
some beer you son of a [ __ ]
tyrus
you gotta love that they're trying to
cancel somebody who is who was like on
an online class
that's pretty funny where's where's dean
warms her when you need him be warmer
yeah just
send him home if you're so if we can't
do anything for you if you're afraid of
the internet
then maybe get off your phone yeah i'm
saying like these and i'm assuming this
is a huge group four or five six hundred
thousand members strong that have all
these demands i think it should be done
in a very tasteful no
hell no and go to school somewhere else
yeah because we i just like i don't have
the right to determine who i want to go
to school if i don't like somebody i
don't want my neighbor's kid going to
the same school as my daughter so i'm
pulling like he needs to he can't go
because he eats paint you know what i'm
saying it's not it's not for me yeah
determined and it's the same thing here
so they're getting their little moment
and they're the little socialists and
all other kind of let them go somewhere
else because what do you need education
for your socials you're sharing
everything that's that's that's what
kill i
i mean
they're more dangerous yeah a socialist
group cat are more dangerous than
anything kyle written rittenhouse was
found innocent because he acted in
self-defense you can agree disagree
whatever but the socialists as a group
have done more harm to the world than
most organizations on the planet and
that is a scientific fact although i
just made it up here
it's hard because on the one hand i'm
like should men be allowed on the
internet
trust me you one look at my instagram
comments you'd be like she has a point
uh but no obviously like they really
love to protest the things because they
don't have to add anything they just
hate things and they protest things so
they don't care that he's online they
can always come up with the reason right
that you know it's the safe space it's
whatever you want it to be right if you
say you don't feel safe you're not safe
and therefore you have to march forward
you don't have to actually have any
reasons or do anything or add anything
and you can just tear other things down
which is probably a lot easier and
social by the way what if you're not you
don't feel safe around socialists since
socialists want to take your stuff and
and redistribute it like it's like can't
you it's like i don't feel safe i mean
socialists have been responsible for so
much death for over you know centuries
it's like why i mean if anything i don't
feel safe around socialist susan let's
say you i agree with you because didn't
mao kill
40 million people
with the great leap forward or whatever
you starve them to death exactly but i
think it's also hypocritic for these
students to say well we're gonna adhere
our justice because didn't they accuse
rittenhouse of taking justice into his
own hands
so the court said he's innocent but yet
these students say well we're gonna
we're gonna say you're guilty we're
gonna take away your rights for being at
school yeah they're stupid
that's my conclusion todd asu i grew up
thinking that that's never going to go
to that school it's a party school you
won't learn anything but this is worse
than being a party school it's like it's
like wokism has come to asu and
extracted the fun and replaced it with
miserable losers well that's why it
falls on the school to and excuse my
french grow a pear in this circle
oh
pyro said grow up here did you are you
talking about the actual fruit or
testicles
because i love a good pear i didn't do
anything i love a good pear i will
bite right
[Applause]
but the overall point i think i'm
building upon what tyra said we have to
stop treating these children as adults
their children masquerading as adults
they make these demands who are they to
make demands and you see it it's not
just in the schools greg it has gone
over to dare i say congress you have
these four or five people making demands
of the entire congress that are on this
socialist left and look the democrats
cave to them and try to formulate their
whole policy plan for them it has to
stop it has to be nipped in the bud they
did not win the votes they do not make
up the predominance of asu it has to
stop now yeah and the thing is
he's getting a lot of applause tonight
this young man
and the thing is uh when you're watching
people appease to these demands it's
over like the little pronoun hysteria
happened because like a small segment of
society says we don't like he and she
and then and it's it's like and jordan
peterson called it out when it started
if you give into this speech is done and
he was right